soit la polémique sur les prix
effectivement vous avez posé une
question qui est particulièrement
complexe et
avec avec plusieurs aspects qui pour moi
sont utiles à rappeler d'abord sur
le les deux sujets qui se mélangent dans
le champ du du prix pour moi
ils sont vraiment totalement distincts
il y a le premier sujet que vous avez
cité qui est est-ce qu'on a pas tiré le
prix des médicaments matures un peu trop
bas c'était votre première question et
puis la seconde qui est un peu en miroir
c'est quel est le prix réel de
l'innovation
et donc sur ces deux questions vous le
savez la première ministre a lancé une
mission il y a quelques jours donc
évidemment on sera très attentif à
attendre des conclusions de cette
mission il se trouve que moi j'ai une
position un petit peu particulière en
tant que directeur général de la Santé
et d'autre part en tant que médecin
universitaire qui continue à
m'intéresser à la littérature
scientifique
il est très difficile de savoir à quoi
correspond objectivement le prix
d'innovation ça c'est un sujet alors il
y a un article que je me permets de vous
citer qui est évidemment pas français et
pas dans une revue française donc il y a
aucun lien d'intérêt particulier c'est
un article qui est sorti dans dans le
brutisme médical journal il y a quelques
jours en février
et qui nous interroge collectivement sur
la construction du prix d'innovation je
trouve que c'est une approche
intéressante puisque dans ces dans ces
messages
c'est un travail de recherche qui
reprend
l'histoire des grandes entreprises
pharmaceutiques et notamment
de celles qui sont les plus mobilisés
sur la recherche et développement et qui
justement s'interroge sur le fait que
finalement
dans ce Prix de l'Innovation il y a
objectivement d'autres d'autres dépenses
que celle de la recherche et
d'innovation il peut y avoir des
dépenses qui sont réelles mais dépenses
qui sont pas forcément dans le champ de
la recherche et du développement et que
à chaque fois aussi se pose la question
mais ça vous le savez que c'est un débat
que nous avons entre expert sur les
avantages cliniques et thérapeutiques
qu'apporte l'innovation par rapport à au
traitement existants il peut y avoir des
vrais pas des vraies ruptures mais
parfois des évolutions modestes
et puis par ailleurs il y a des
innovations qui peuvent être extrêmement
intéressantes sur le plan médical et qui
ne sont pas forcément très coûteuses
donc tout ça tout ça fait que il y a une
réflexion très importante alors je crois
que ce matin vous vous écoute vous
entendiez le président des ceps et je
voudrais juste dire deux mots sur le
rôle que nous souhaitons nous jouer au
niveau européen parce que je pense que
la réponse une réponse partielle sur les
enjeux de prix du médicament passe par
l'Europe nous nous sommes très impliqués
sur ce qu'on appelle le NCP le ncapr
c'est à dire le rôle des autorités
compétentes nationales dans le
l'établissement du prix vous savez que
ça fait partie des réflexions qui sont
en cours et qui sont issus notamment de
la PFE sur le fait que nous avons
encouragé très fortement le partage
d'informations au niveau européen
puisque c'était ça aussi le le risque
dans le paysage c'était que chacun avait
sa propre politique et que chacun
gardait ses informations donc comment
est-ce qu'on partage l'information
comment on partage les expériences entre
les pays de l'Union européenne
sur les initiatives de prix sur les
remboursements sur la production et les
capacités d'efforts donc ça a été de
très nombreux groupes de travail ça a
été évidemment des
des enjeux de critères adaptés de
critères partagés et la DGS soutient
très fortement la mise en œuvre d'un
règlement à la fois pour renforcer le
rôle de l'Agence européenne du
médicament et je me permets de souligner
que la directrice générale de l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament un
poste très élevé et très important à
l'EMA et c'est très bien pour la France
donc on pèse dans cette agence
européenne qui qui est en cours de
renforcement et on est très ambitieux
pour cette agence qui a de nouvelles
capacité qui peut maintenant mieux
surveiller les pénuries qui peut mieux
intervenir en urgence dans les
événements majeurs qui peut éviter donc
les crises de santé publique en pilotant
davantage la réponse